[Musique]
candidat suivant sur prêts bonjour au
jour entrer à l'entrée asseyez-vous bien
merci d'être venus et puis bah pour
commencer je vais vous demander votre
nom batman batman d'accord béate et mnc
101ème d'accord pour faire homme chauve
souris c'est ça ouais c'est marrant donc
si je me trompe pas vous venez pour le
poste d'assistant cessa d'associer non
assistant à sur l'annoncé marque est
associée vous faites une erreur
bref quels sont vos particularités
qu'est ce que vous pouvez apporter un
peu dans cette histoire alors pour
commencer j'ai une cape que j'ai élaboré
moi même et quand je fais comme ça je
plane sur plusieurs mètres
d'accord moi je vole
voilà vous avez autre chose jean les
grappins je m'en sers surtout pour
grimper sur le toit des bâtiments
d'accord j'ai bien compris en fait moi
pour faire ça je vole dire que je parle
d'en bas et jeu ok sinon j'ai une
batmobile est sa spécificité s'est
attardé je suis désolé je vous coupez en
faites quoi tout ce qui est moyen de
locomotion
ça m'intéresse pas parce que je vole et
s'il pleut par exemple bon sinon niveau
bayard comment vous en sentez techniques
de combats à ben alors là je suis
imbattable justement tous qui corps à
corps
disons que je maîtrise pas d'accord donc
s'il ya un monstre géant kathak la ville
vous pouvez gérer étant donné que
j'aurai besoin de développer du matériel
spécifique aux laboratoires j'aurai
besoin de juste un petit peu de temps
pour analyser la structure moléculaire
de la créature mais oui ça pourrait
poser de problème non mais là on parle
combat rapproché vous contre la créature
à mains nues quoi ah ouais bah non
d'accord mais vous avez affronté qui par
exemple le joker ah oui c'est le
monsieur qui est habillé en clown c'est
ça c'est le monsieur qui se veut bien
plus d'accord débat très bien très bien
et sinon niveau armes vous avez quoi un
boomerang un moment j'ai une arme lui
que ça j'en ai une énorme mais là aller
à la maison parce que c'était pas
pratiquer en fait à déplacer à cause du
fait qu'elle est qu'elle est trop
puissante quoi ah oui c'est vous qui
tirez des lasers avec les yeux c'est ça
non ça c'est vous oui c'est pas très
bien merci d'être venus et puis si vous
êtes retenu pour le poste d'assistant
associé ce temps ma secrétaire vous
rappellera au revoir monsieur batman
voilà c'est ça la petite chauve-souris
allez au revoir
candidat suivant si si et vous je vous
en prie vous venez de croiser le
candidat précédent s'est pas très bien
passé j'espère que vous allez relever le
niveau
alors avant de commencer je vais vous
demander votre man hulk